PHILADELPHIA. IT TURNED OUT
CARSON WENTZ WASN'T GOOD
ENOUGH NOR WAS DOUG PETERSON
NOR WAS A LOT OF GUYS WHO HAD
BEEN
ON THE ROSTER.
SINCE THEY WON THE SUPER BOWL
THREE YEARS AGO. THERE IS A
LONG ARTICLE IN THE ATHLETIC
AND WHEN I SAY LAW IT'S LONG
AND I APOLOGIZE THAT I JUST
DON'T HAVE IT IN ME TO READ
ALL OF THESE LONG-ASS
ARTICLES. I'M SORRY. I STILL
BELIEVE YOU SHOULD GET A
T-SHIRT. IF YOU CAN PROVE
THAT YOU READ ONE OF THESE
THINGS START TO FINISH AND I
WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU THAT NOT
MANY T-SHIRTS WOULD HAVE TO
BE MADE BECAUSE I DOUBT THAT
EVEN THE MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA
WHO SHOUT FROM ON HIGH. WHAT
A GREAT THING IT IS IT'S
THIS LONG ARTICLE WAS WRITTEN.
THEY DON'T READ ALL OF IT
RAIN, SORRY JUST TO WHAT
GRAMPS I HAVE TO CAN I ADMIT
I DIDN'T READ ALL OF IT. HOW
CAN ANYONE AT A CERTAIN POINT
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENS YOU START
READING WITH EVERY INTENT
WITH EVERY INTENT. I'M GOING
TO READ IT. I'M GOING TO READ
IT. I'M GOING TO READ IT AND
THEN AFTER ABOUT FIVE OR SIX
PARAGRAPHS, IT'S SCROLL
SCROLL SCROLL SCROLL. LOOK
FOR SOMETHING THAT JUMPS OFF
THE PAGE. ISN'T THAT WHAT WE
ALL DO ISN'T THAT WHAT WE DO?
SO WHY WRITE A LONG-ASS
ARTICLE LIKE THAT? WHAT AM I
MISSING?
I LIKE TO RIDE THEM IT YOU
JUST DO MY GOD. I AGREE WITH
IT. YOU DON'T HAVE TIME
ENOUGH TO READ THEM. YOU
DON'T NOBODY DOES. YEAH, I
MEAN IT'S IN THIS DAY AND AGE
THE WAY THINGS ARE MOVING THE
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE IN THE
BUSINESS, YOU DON'T HAVE TIME
TO SHUT YOUR WORKDAY DOWN FOR
45 MINUTES AND STUDY A LONG
ARTICLE. I APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT. I'M NOT BEING WELL, I
AM BEING CRITICAL. I MEAN
CRITICAL OF THE WHOLE THE
WHOLE MINDSET LIKE LIKE IT.
SO THIS IS A GOOD
THING. IT'S NOT
GOOD THING ANYMORE. MAYBE IT
WAS A GOOD THING YEARS AGO
WHEN THEY ACTUALLY PRINTED
THINGS ON PAPER AND PEOPLE
WAITED TO GET SPORTS
ILLUSTRATED AND IT WAS
ACTUALLY MORE THAN A
FIVE-PAGE PAMPHLET THE THING
THAT CAME TO YOUR HOUSE.
MAYBE IT WAS A GOOD THING
THEN WE HAD NOTHING BETTER TO
DO. WE DIDN'T HAVE PHONES
RIGHT? WE HAD FOUR CHANNELS
ON THE TV, BUT IT'S IT TAKES
TOO MUCH TIME. NO ONE IS
SAVORING THE POETRY OF SPORTS
WRITING ANYMORE. I'M SORRY.
THEY'RE NOT SHIREEN. IT'S A
DIFFERENT WORLD. IT'S
TRANSACTIONAL. IT'S
INFORMATIONAL. TELL ME WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED IS SHOCKER.
THERE'S DYSFUNCTION IN
PHILADELPHIA AND THERE IS
SOME SOME COMPELLING
EXPLANATION OF THE WAY THAT
DOUG PETERSON ALLEGEDLY
REPORTEDLY WAS TREATED BY THE
TEAM MICROMANAGE. EVERY
TUESDAY GOT CALLED INTO THE
PRINCIPAL'S OFFICE AND HAD TO
EXPLAIN HIMSELF AWAY. EVEN
WHEN THEY BEAT THE PACKERS ON
THURSDAY NIGHT IN THE 2019
SEASON WHEN IT WAS THE ONLY
HOME LOSS THE PACKERS HAD FOR
A LONG TIME IN THE MAT
LAFLEUR REGIME HAD TO ANSWER
A BUNCH OF QUESTIONS ABOUT
THAT. WHY AREN'T YOU PAST
ANYMORE AND IT'S THAT TENSION.
BETWEEN ANALYTICS AND
FOOTBALL ANALYTICS IN
FOOTBALL ONE OF THE THINGS IN
THERE THAT VALIDATES ONE OF
MY BELIEFS ABOUT THE CURRENT
STATE OF THE NFL SHIREEN THE
OWNERS AND THE ANALYTICS
PEOPLE HAVE A TIGHTER BOND
THAN THE OWNERS AND THE
FOOTBALL PEOPLE AND THE
AND THE FOOTBALL PEOPLE AND
THE ANALYTICS PEOPLE HAVE A
HELL OF A LOT MORE SWAY THAN
WE REALIZE OVER THE OWNER THE
ONE WHO ULTIMATELY MAKES THE
BIG DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE THE
YEAH, I AGREE WITH YOU MIKE.
AND I THINK WE'VE SEEN THAT
WE'VE SEEN IT WITH THE BUNCH
OF ORGANIZATIONS. I DON'T
KNOW IF EVERY ORGANIZATION IS
LIKE THAT BUT A BUNCH OF THEM
HAVE GONE THAT WAY NO
QUESTION AND YOU LOOK EVEN
WHEN THAT ARTICLE TALKED
ABOUT THE 2017 SEASON IF THE
EAGLES HAD GOTTEN OFF TO A
SLOW START THEY WERE ALREADY
PREPARING TO REPLACE DOUG
PETERSON. AND OF COURSE, THEY
GOT OFF TO A TEN-IN-ONE START
AND ENDED UP WINNING THE
SUPER BOWL THAT YEAR SO THAT
DIDN'T HAPPEN, BUT IT'S
AMAZING TO ME HOW THIS
ORGANIZATION HAS FALLEN APART.
SO
QUICKLY, I MEAN 2017 RIGHT
THERE SUPER BOWL CHAMPIONS
THEY END.
THIS LONG RUN OF NOT HAVING A
CHAMPIONSHIP TEAM OVER 50
YEARS AND THEY WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN THIS WHOLE THING ISTHCO'
SO MUCH FEELS LIKE THEY'RE IN
REBUILD MOLD THEIR 22 AND 25
AND ONE SINCE THAT SUPER BOWL
AND I JUST DON'T KNOW HOW IT
WENT. SO WRONG SO FAST, BUT
IT CERTAINLY DID. I KNOW
CARSON WENTZ PLAYED A PART IN
THAT BUT IT JUST SOUNDS LIKE
THIS WAS A TEAM AND
DYSFUNCTION EVEN BEFORE THEY
WON THE SUPER BOWL MIKE.
YEAH, AND THEY GOT A LOT TO
DO TO TURN IT AROUND AND
THEY'RE A TEAM THAT I
MENTIONED ON FRIDAY IN AN
ITEM AT PFT STILL KEEP AN EYE
ON THEM AS POTENTIAL DESHAUN
WATSON DESTINATION AT SOME
POINT. THEY'RE THE TEAM THAT
GAVE MIKE VICK IS SECOND
CHANCE AFTER HIS LEGAL ISSUES
OF 2007 THROUGH 2009. I'M NOT
SAYING NOW I'M NOT SAYING
SOON I'M SAYING WHENEVER
WHEREVER THE DESHAUN WATSON
CAREER CONTINUES DO NOT RULE
OUT THE PHILADELPHIA EAGLES
UNLESS THEY HAVE
BETTER THAN DESHAUN WATSON AT
THE TIME. HE BECOMES
AVAILABLE THE KANSAS CITY